green grocer pedro gomez says his
business one of small margins has gotten
even tougher these past two years
he hopes portugal's snap election on
sunday leads to a political consensus
that propels portugal out of the
pandemic right now
businesses are being strangled by higher
taxes more than ever
and it's been hard to cope with that
and ever since kovit hit it's been
crisis over crisis
uh
and for small businesses that's uh
that's
really hard to deal with
the overwhelming majority of seats on
sunday will go to both of portugal's two
leading parties the ruling socialists on
the left and the center-right opposition
party the social democrats the election
was called in november when the
socialists former coalition partners the
communists and the leftist bloc
voted with right-wing parties to kill
the 2022 budget
bouncing back from the pandemic is the
top concern for many voters prime
minister antonio costa oversaw one of
the most successful vaccination
campaigns in europe and the government
has helped bring unemployment down to
pre-pandemic levels
some voters are worried though that the
government is at risk of missing out of
billions of dollars in eu recovery funds
if they don't meet certain requirements
polls show cost to socialists holding a
slight edge over the social democrats
few voters though are fired up
i don't have a lot of hope in the
election i'm still not sure which party
to support maybe it's better if we have
a coalition
when voters go to the polls here on
sunday they could end up electing a new
government whether it be on the left or
the right that further polarizes
portuguese politics rather than bringing
parties to the center that's how
political scientist antonio costa pinto
sees it the two major parties will face
basically the same type of challenges if
the socialists win
they will have problems in negotiated
with their left the communist and the
left-wing bloc if the social democrat
wins they will have problems in
negotiate with agreement with
the radical right-wing populist party
a party expected to make gains on sunday
could be shaga a far right wing party
formed just three years ago currently
holding just one seat it could win as
many as a dozen according to polls
portugal the poorest country in western
europe has struggled for decades to
catch up with richer countries in the
block
brazilian immigrant eddie consigliere
doesn't believe the next government will
do much better
for me the politics is the same all over
the world
politicians fight to hold the country
back and not move forward it's a fight
for power who will win that power and
what they'll do with it has many here
uneasy about the future adam rainey al
jazeera lisbon